bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du Sénat pour cet après-midi
la séance des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement parmi les thèmes qui vont
être abordés par les sénateurs deux
questions sur la pression fiscale trois
questions sur la pression fiscale cet
après-midi au Sénat notamment celle de
pierreel euh secrétaire national du
Parti communiste et sénateur de Paris
deux questions sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui Contin continu à
faire couler beaucoup d'ancre ici au
Sénat et puis jour de manifestation et
de grève dans les établissements
scolaires aujourd'hui la séance des
questions d'actualité débutera avec une
question de François repsamen le
président du groupe socialiste ici au
Sénat il va interpeller le Premier
ministre jean-marquero sur les
comportements
antirépublicains je pense qu'il fait
allusion au sifflé du 11 novembre contre
François Hollande sans doute également
aux attaques racistes contre Christiane
tobira donc ce sera la séance à suivre à
partir de 15h en direct sur notre
antenne alors que vous le voyez sur les
images les sénateurs qui arrivent dans
cette salle des conférences juste à côté
de l'hémicycle du Sénat notre invité
avant cette séance et bien c'est Alain
vidalis bonjour ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement merci d'être
avec nous François Hollande avait promis
pendant sa campagne présidentielle de
l'apaisement et puis 18 mois après son
élection on a la grande sociale on a des
manifestations on a du racisme qui
émerge où est l'apaisement promis à
vidalis sur la question sociale
l'apaisement promis par le Président de
la République c'était la méthode et il a
utilisé cette méthode on l'a vu dans la
négociation qui a abouti au contrat de
génération dans la négociation qui a
abouti à l'accord national
interprofessionnel sur le marché du
travail donc l'apaisement c'est une
méthode ça s'oppose à à l'affrontement
ou à la méthode brutale donc il a
appliqué qui conduit à l'exaspération un
peu partout aujourd'hui dans le pays oui
mais aujourd'hui qu'il y ait des
difficultés je pense que c'est une
réalité mais en même temps la politique
que nous avons voulu mettre en œuvre
demander des efforts aux Français parce
que c'était absolument nécessaire pour
combler les déficites on n'a pas choisi
nous de d'arriver au pouvoir avec une
telle situation et soit on s'en lavait
les mains et on continua à endetter la
France soit on disait aux Français il y
aura un effort et il va être réparti
justement on est dans cette période où
malgré tout aujourd'hui nous avons des
espoirs de croissance pour 2014 pour
2015 qui font que la question
prioritaire pour les Français la
question de l'emploi pourrait enfin
trouver une solution ou mais toujours
est-il que les Français ne comprennent
pas aujourd'hui cette méthode si on en
juge l'état d'exaspération de la la
société telle qu'elle est décrite dans
une note qui a été rendue publique une
note des préfets qui remonte au
ministère de de
l'intérieur tu parles les mots sont
assez forts d'une société en colère oui
mais ça c'est pas le le président de la
République parce que la colère ça fait
pas une politique quand vous avez un
mouvement dans une région où à la fois
manifeste les gens qui licencient ça
peutêtre la réaction à une politique
c'est pas une politique mais ça
peut-être la réaction à cette polique
làou mais mais une c'est pas une réponse
politique c'est pas une politique
alternative c'est des intérêts qui sont
totalement contradictoires qu'est-ce que
propose aujourd'hui ceux qui veulent une
politique alternative on sait la folie
enfin ce que pourrait représenter la
solution proposée par l'extrême droite
et quand à la droite on sait quelle
serait quelle serait sa politique
alternative c'est la politique qui a été
é présenté dans le cadre du débat sur le
budget à l'Assemblée nationale encore
moins de service public encore plus
d'efforts pour les Français donc c'est
pas je crois ce que souhaitent les
Français la France est dans une
situation difficile mais il y a qu'une
politique pour la sortir dans tous les
cas c'est notre conviction c'est la
notre la popularité du chef de l'État
pour l'instant est au plus bas on a vu
encore ce sondage ce matin publié par Le
offington Post et Paris télé on parle de
15 % de confiance envers le le chef de
l'État jamais on a été aussi bas oui ça
ça correspond enfin il y a des sondages
plus habituels je préfère prendre ceux
qui sont publiés régulièrement plutôt
que ce sondage singulier mais c'est vrai
que la côte de popularité est est basse
mais au fond est-ce que c'est surprenant
quand vous avez le courage de faire une
politique on dit toujours ce président
n'a pas de courage vous savez le courage
c'est souvent aussi de demander de
demander des efforts et le président de
la République il a le courage
aujourd'hui de dire aux Français il y a
pas d'autres solution il faut faire ces
efforts là et donc c'est vrai que
peut-être la difficulté c'est que ces
efforts ne sont pas compris ou dans tous
les cas que les Français disent bon des
efforts jusqu'à quand mais ils doivent
se dire que on commence et les chiffres
qu'on nous donne pour la croissance en
2014 même si ça reste pas encore op chif
pour l'stant sont mauvais encore ce
matin à l'inv mais les chires ce
matinro voilà je ve dire vous pouvez
commenter le - 01 de ce matin mais oui
mais le trimestre dernier c'était + 0,5
et donc si on avait fait plus 02 + 02
vous direz ça va bien le tout c'est
c'est la tendance ça aurait été bien si
on MOS 0,1 dernier trimestre serait plus
05 à celui-ci mais c'est l'inverse donc
ça va plutôt dans sens parce que c'est
des phéomè enfin c'est assez classique P
dans les mois d'été c'est des périodes
conjoncturelles on le sait bien et c'est
pas une surprise au fond la surprise
pour nous c'est qu'on avait dit que ça
serait é0 c'est -1 bon c'est le c'est le
trait de ligne mais on va - 01 mais on
va avoir une année qui sera enfin une
année où on va être à + 01 ou + 02 en
fonction des chiffres du 4e trimestre
qui vont être meilleurs puis une année
2014 sur lequel on nous dit + 09
peut-être 1 % bon les perspectives sont
bonnes ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
relâcher l'effort et puis surtout des
des grandes mesures qu'on a mis en œuvre
notamment cette décision pas si simple
de mettre 20 milliards pour les
entreprises elle va donner tout son
effet dans l'année 2014 avec le cice
mais vous entendez ce que vous dites
vous dites les perspectives sont bonnes
et quand vous avez tant de
manifestations de colèrees qui
s'expriment est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les Français entendent
ce message-l mais de toutç la politique
c'est de la pédagogie aujourd'hui
justement l'imession man de la pédagogie
aujourd'hui je suis là pour ça ce que
fait le président de la République ce
font les les les ministres tous les
jours on n'a pas euh inventé la
situation et on essaie d'apporter des
réponses ce qui compte pour les Français
c'est qu'il se demande quelle autre
politique pourrait être menée C'est ça
la vraie question s'il y avait une
crédibilité à une politique alternative
vous savez une politique une politique
dans laquelle on p oui non c'est la
question qui se pose quand on va
protester c'est pour changer de
politique et changer de politique au
profit de quel politique si c'est
aujourd'hui s'il y a des gens encore qui
croient qu'on peut redresser les comptes
garantir les services public et
augmenter les salaires sans strictement
rien faire ça ça n'est ça n'est pas
possible et je crois qu'au fond d'ux les
Français le savent bien donc qu'est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux averser d'ici la fin de
l'année est-ce que c'est la courbe de la
popularité du chef de l'État ou la
courbe du chômage mais vous savez je
pense que ça sera très lié ça sera ça
sera très lié et comme la courbe du
chômage va s'inverser à la fin de
l'année je pense que la courbe de
popularité du président commencera
recommencer mais le chef de l'État avait
parlé le 14 juillet dernier dans son
intervention d'une confiance d'une
reprise dans dans l'économie on voit
bien quand même avec le chiffre publié
ce matin de de la croissance 0,1 % qu'on
en est loin non je partage pas votre
avis ce qui est important aujourd'hui et
vous auriez raison si on avit des
perspectives pour l'année prochaine qui
soit à nouveau des perspectives à zéro
ou à zé non on a une perspective à 0,9
ce que dit tout le monde on pense plutôt
d'ailleurs que ça sera autour de de de 1
% bon je veux dire les perspectives
elles sont pas mérifiques mais elles
sont bonnes on est sur le bon chemin et
je crois qu'il faut se tenir à cette
politique on va parler de ce qui s'est
passé ce matin au Sénat Alain vidalise
des débats assez vifs on n'est pas
toujours habitué dans cette maison quand
le gouvernement a demandé une seconde
délibération à vot bloquer sur le budget
pour 2014 de la sécurité sociale budget
qui a finalement été rejeté euh par le
Sénat ce matin ça on s'y attendait mais
ce qui était quand même frappant c'est
d'entendre les discours des uns et des
autres euh sur les bancs à gauche comme
à droite hein pas au Parti socialiste
mais les bans des communistes les bans
de de l'UMP ce discours dans lequel
s'exprimait finalement euh une forme de
mépris de la part du gouvernement vers
le Sénat qu'est-ce que vous répondez au
sénateur écoutez j'ai j'ai exactement
l'opinion
inverse il faut imaginer ce qui serait
passé si mais là aussi il va falloir la
pédagogie parce que ils sont plutôt
convaincus du contraire oui mais c'est
assez simple qu'est-ce qui serait passé
si le gouvernement n'avit pas pris cette
initiative il se serait passé exactement
la même chose que sur le vote sur les
retraites c'est-à-dire qu'ici au Sénat
le gouvernement n'a pas de majorité et
quand on présente un texte certains
texte sur tous les articles il y a des
majorités est contre avec l'alliance de
la droite et du groupe communiste pour
des raisons inverses mais qui vote
contre et à la fin on a un texte qui qui
ressemble plus à rien si on nait pas
pris d'initiative de demander un vote
bloqué de demander un vote bloqué une
deuxième délibération alors le texte
lesat de texte qui serait resté à la fin
et qui ressemblait plus à rien aurait
été rejeté par tout le monde et à ce
momentl comme pour le texte sur les
retraites c'estd ce qui aurait été ce
qui aurait été incompréhensible pour les
Français c'est un vote qui soit 348 à zé
et il fallait bien montrer qu'il y avait
des gens ici qui étaient pour le texte
présenté par le gouvernement qu'ils
étaient minoritaires ou plus exactement
qu'il n'y a pas de majorité alternative
pour une autre politique mais il y a une
majorité des des des contes et je pense
franchement que défendre l'institution
du Sénat c'est bien remettre de la
politique dans ce vote et ne pas laisser
cette chose incompréhensible d'un texte
qui aurait été refusé par l'ensemble des
sénateurs le gouvernement je suis
personnellement très attaché au
bicamérisme et au rôle du Sénat et je
pense qu'on a du service au Sénat en
remettant de la politique dans ce vote
mais pourtant les sénateurs n'ont pas
beaucoup l'impression d'être entendu
beaucoup de ministres sans remettre
beaucoup à l'Assemblée nationale qui
finalement à le dernier mot on le sait
inconstitutionnellement parlant sur les
projets de loi c'est une mauvaise
appréciation le président belle a publié
lui-même des statistiques il y a eu plus
de propositions de loi émanant du Sénat
qui ont été définitivement adopté depuis
le début de la législature que venant de
l'Assemblée nationale ça c'est des
chiffres c'est pas des commentaires
c'est pas de la petite politique et et
quand il y a une majorité ici comme la
semaine dernière sur l'économie sociale
et solidaire et bien le Sénat participe
et même quand les textes ne sont pas
voté au Sénat par exemple celui que j'ai
porté sur la transparence même si le
débat avait été difficile ici deux
dispositions essentielles de ce texte
ont été repris par l'Assemblée nationale
malgré ces difficultés le Sénat continue
à apporter sa pierre à l'édifice
législatif c'est ça qui est important
encore quelques questions d'actualité
àin vidalis alors qu'on vient de le voir
sur ces images le Premier ministre
Jean-Marc HUD est arrivé dans dans la
salle des conférences une question pour
revenir sur la fiscalité puisqu'il va y
avoir deux interpellations des des
sénateurs tout à l'heure et la grande
contre la TVA est-ce que ça a été à
votre avis une erreur de faire voter
cette hausse de la TVA en 2012 pour une
application au 1er janvier 2014 est-ce
que ça je pense je pense que c'est pas
une erreur il y a une explication on a
fait un choix politique il peut être
discuté il est très clair nous avons
constaté que l'économie française avait
perdu en compétitivité et le Crédit
Impôt compétitivité les 20 milliards
sont finan par la hausse de la TVA ça
consiste en résumé à baisser le coût du
travail en France de 4 % pour retrouver
quoi le chemin de la compétitivité et
donc celui de la croissance un choix
politique mais nous l'assumons en tant
que tel ouis mais les Français sont
peut-être un petit peu perdus puisqu'ils
ont peut-êt l'impression pendant la
campagne présidentielle que finalement
François Hollande refusait la TVA
sociale de Nicolas Sarkozi et puis Bou
il fait voter une augmentation de la TVA
donc ils ont peut-être l'impression les
Français d'avoir été trahis non vous
avez raison parce que n'it pas idée au
moment où on est arrivé de l'ampleur du
désastre et que il y a eu le rapport
Galois entre l'élection présidentielle
et l'augmentation de la TVA il y a eu le
rapport Galois et ce rapport Galois
demandé par le Président de la
République et le Premier ministre il dit
la France a un énorme problème de
compétitivité vous pouvez quand même
admettre que le problème de
compétitivité de la France il est pas né
entre mai 2012 et septembre 2012 c'est
simplement à ce moment-là ce constat
est-ce qu'il fallait rester les bras
croisés non et si on voulait trouver
hétaitixix courux une toute petite
dernière question avant de vous laisser
rejoindre l'hémicycle parce qu'on entend
la sonnerie retentir est-ce que vous
allez donner un avis favorable à
l'amendement de François Marc pour la
commission des finances sur l'extension
de la taxe à 75 % à l'AS Monaco un club
de foot qui est affilié à la Fédération
Française de de foot écoutez je je je ne
sais pas parce que j'ai pas vu le
ministre du Budget est-ce que c'est
possible je ne sais pas non plus sur le
plan du principe ça me paraît cousu de
de bon sens et par conséquent si c'est
possible pourquoi pas très bien merci
beaucoup Alain vidalis d'avoir répondu
en direct à nos questions je vais vous
laisser rejoindre l'hémicycle du Sénat
on a vu que Jean-Marc HUD le Premier
ministre venait de rentrer dans
l'hémicycle c'est Thierry foucco
vice-président communiste du Sénat qui
va présider cette séance puisque
jean-perre belle le président du Sénat
est en ce moment en Nouvelle-Calédonie
il fait tout un périple en Océanie pour
représenter la France notamment pour les
commémorations le weekend dernier du 11
novembre et donc Jean-Pierre belle est
absent aujourd'hui c'est Thierry fouco
qui va présenter présider pardon cette
séance à sa place je rappelle parmi les
thèmes qui vont être abordés par les
sénateur cet après-midi et bien trois
interpellations autour de la hausse de
la fiscalité de la pression fiscale
notamment cette question de Pierre
Laurent le secrétaire national du Parti
communiste qui nous rejoindra ensuite
sur ce plateau pour débattre de la
fiscalité deux questions également
autour de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires alors que c'est une journée de
grève aujourd'hui dans les écoles et et
qu'il y a plusieurs collectifs de maires
qui se montent contre cette réforme et
puis que la semaine prochaine il y aura
le Congrès des maires à Paris et donc ça
sera un peu un pic de contestation à
craindre pour le gouvernement autour de
cette réforme des rythmes scolaires et
puis la séance des questions d'actualité
va commencer cet après-midi par une
interpellation une question de François
repsamen le président du groupe
socialiste ici au Sénat François
repsamen qui va interpeller le Premier
ministre Jean-Marc HUD sur les
comportements
antirépublicain une question qui fait
évidemment directement allusion au
sifflet dont a été victime le chef de
l'État le 11 novembre sur les
Champs-Élysées également aux attaques
racistes contre la garde des saut
Christian tobira c'est le premier
ministre qui devrait normalement
répondre à cette interpellation à cette
question de François repsamen donc voilà
pour pour les principaux thèmes
d'actualité qui vont être abordés dans
l'hémicycle dis sénna cet après-midi
cette séance qui devrait démarrer d'une
minute à l'autre on a vu sur les images
les ministres arrivés les uns après les
autres ainsi que le premier ministre
Jean marquerot donc tout le monde
s'installe voilà la cloche retenti je
vous laisse suivre cette séance on se
retrouve ensuite avec nos invités sur ce
plateau en direct à tout à l'heure chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que le ou le ministre pour sa
réponse dispose chacun de 2 minutes 30
la parole est à Monsieur François
remsamen pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues monsieurs les
ministres mesdames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le Premier ministre
ma question s'adresse directement à vous
en quelques jours notre pays a vu se
succéder un certain nombre de faits
inacceptables qui sonnent comme des
signaux alarmants sur l'état de notre
société il y a les injures racistes dont
a fait l'objet madame la garde des saau
et je veux ici à cette occasion malgré
son absence puisquelle est retenue à
Marseille solennellement en mon nom au
nom de mes collègues sénateurs
socialistes et je le crois au nom de mes
collègues de l'ensemble de cette
assemblée lui dire notre indignation
devant ces attaques inqualifiables et
l'assuré de notre soutien de notre
estime de notre respect et j'ajouterai
de notre
amitié merci Mones chers
collègues
il y a également les incidents honteux
qui ont flétri la journée de
commémoration du 11 novembre au mépris
du respect et de la reconnaissance dû au
combattants mort pour la France il y a
les coups de couteau portés à un député
maire et à ses adjoints et je veux ici
exprimer aussi ma solidarité et celle de
mon groupe à ces élus agressés dans
l'exercice de leur mandat
républicain il y a des débordements
dangereux Monsieur le Premier Ministre
des manifestations contre les cô taxes
il y a enfin les appels à la
désobéissance civile de la part d'élus
qui annonce vouloir refuser d'appliquer
la loi je parle ici bien évidemment de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires toutous
C faits toutous C faits mes chers
collègues n'ont pas la même gravité
n'ont pas la même gravité ni les mêmes
racines certains certains portent la
marque ou l'empreinte de l'extrême
droite ils sont très préoccupants car
ils montrent que les digues ont été
rompues que les actes et les paroles de
haine sont libéré et que je le crois
notre pacte républicain est en danger
d'autres proviennent de comportement de
l'opposition politicien mais ils n'en
sont pas moins graves car ils apportent
confusion et malaise aux Français
fragilisés par la crise inquiet pour
leur avenir et impatient de voir les
résultats des efforts qu'ils ont
consentis monsieur le Premier ministre
depuis 18 mois avec votre gouvernement
vous menez politique courageuse pour
redresser notre pays dans la justice et
mener à bien les réformes
indispensables au nom des sénateurs
socialistes je tiens à rendre ici
hommage à votre action et à celle de
votre gouvernement cette politique va
porter ses fruits nous en sommes
certains mais Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour rassurer les Français qui
en doute pouvez-vous retracer les
grandes lignes de votre action et nous
dire les résultats que vous en attendez
dans les semaines qui viennent je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le Président repsamen merci de
du message que vous venez d'exprimer de
soutien à mon gouvernement en effet nous
sommes engagé dans une œuvre difficile
qui est celle du redressement de la
France cela demande des efforts cela
demande des réformes des réformes
souvent structurelles je prendrai un
exemple croyez-vous qu'il soit pas
nécessaire d'entreprendre la refondation
de l'école pour permettre la réussite de
tous les
enfants croyez-vous qu'il soit pas
nécessaire d'en faire une
priorité du gouvernement et de la France
oui dans l'intérêt du pays pour la
préparation de l'avenir pour faire en
sorte que tous nos jeunes aent les mêmes
chances de réussite ça ça se fait pas
fac
il y a des conservatismes il y a des
rigidités il y a des corporatismes nous
le savons et en même temps nous avons un
gouvernement qui accepte le dialogue qui
n'hésite pas à négocier qui n'hésite pas
à modifier mais qui ne doit pas perdre
le cap le cap c'est celui du
redressement de la France c'est-à-dire
faire reculer le chômage faire reculer
les inégalités territoriales et sociales
cela demande de l'énergie cela demande
du courage cela demande de la constance
de la cohérence et de la ténacité je
vous remercie monsieur le président du
groupe socialiste François repsamen de
m'apporter votre soutien parce que ce
soutien c'est dans l'intérêt de la
France du pays lui-même et cela cela
nécessite en effet une rigueur dans les
comportements une exigence éthique une
exigence morale un respect de nos lois
un respect de nos règles de tout ce qui
permet à la France d'assurer le vivre
ensemble dans la durée et vous avez eu
raison de
rappeler que dans ces périodes
difficiles il y a des laissés aller il y
a des dérives qui non seulement sont
immorales contraire à notre droit
contraire à nos principes je pense au
racisme je pense à la xénophobie je
pense à l'antisémitisme qui porte
atteinte à la République et à la France
elle-même qui l'affaiblisse et qui lui
per permettent pas de réussir c'est
pourquoi il ne faut rien laisser passer
ce que vous venez de rappeler à juste
titre et mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs de tous les bancs de cette
assemblée lorsque François repsamen a
évoqué la les attaques immonde contre la
garde des sauts vous avez pour la
plupart d'entre vous applaudi ces propos
et je vous en
remercie mais vous
savez au-delà de la personne
elle l'a dit elle-même
elle est c parce que c'est une femme
politique comme chacune et chacun
d'entre nous et d'entre vous accepté
parfois les attaques injustes mais elle
a aussi des proches elle a aussi une
famille et ceux qui se lance dans ses
comportements ces enfants que on a
instrumentalisé à anger présentant une
banane à son intention et bien ceux qui
étaient derrière ces adultes du
tipartisme à la française il font une
atteinte non seulement à la personne
mais une blessure pour la République
elle-même et ça aucun d'entre nous aucun
républicain ne devrait le laisser passer
au contraire devrait tout faire pour le
dénoncer et en tout
cas je vais le redire ici devant la
Haute Assemblée comme je l'ai dit à
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
est décidé à engager toutes les néaire
je l'ai fait moi-même en utilisant
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
après c'est à la justice de se prononcer
elle se prononcera en fonction de nos
lois mais tout atteind à nos lois tout
atteinte à nos règles toute atteinte au
bien public sera condamné avec la plus
grande fermeté parce qu'il n'y a pas de
cohésion nationale il y a pas de
cohésion sociale il y a pas d'adhésion
Pact
républicain autorité de l'État
c'est-à-dire celle issue des lois votées
par le Parlement ne sont pas respecté et
bien j'entends en tant que chef du
gouvernement tout faire pour que la loi
républicaine partout et pour tous soit
la loi de la République et la loi
respectée voilà mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je voulais vous le redire pour
que les choses soient claires je connais
les
souffrances oui je connais les
souffrence qui peuvent exister parce que
telle ou telle région connaît des
mutations parce que lesc n'ont pas été
pris assez tôt parce que certains
secteurs économiques sont en difficulté
parce que des quartiers de nos villes
ont été abandonnés j'étais vendredi
dernier à Marseille et croyez-vous et
Monsieur le Maire de Marseille qui est
là le sa croyez-vous qu'il est digne et
républicain de laisser des quartiers
entiers depuis des années à l'abandon et
bien mon gouvernement a décidé de
relever le défi du redressement
économique social et territorial je
dialoguerai avec tous tous ceux qui sont
prêts à jouer le jeu c'est vrai pour la
brutagne mais c'est vrai aussi pour
d'autres régions mais la France n'est
pas une addition de région et de
territoire la France n'est pas une
adhésion une addition de corporation la
France est une République une et
indivisible laïque et démocratique et
sociale et ça c'est un programme du
gouvernement c'est le programme de mon
gouvernement c'est mon programme pour
agir réduire les fractures sociales et
territoriales permettent à la France de
se retrouver mais se retrouvera que si
elle est suffisamment ferme sur ses
principes et ses valeurs et qu'en aucun
cas y compris ceux qui sont chargés de
faire appliquer la loi de faire de
mettre en œuvre la loi je pense aux élus
ne doivent y déroger parce que
l'exemplarité c'est la garantie aussi de
la cohésion et de de l'adhésion au Pact
national et
républicain
la parole est à Madame caliopi angoela
pour le groupe
écologiste monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Madame Yamina
benigi ministre chargée de la
Francophonie ces derniers jours ont été
marqués par deux grands événements en
lien avec la francophonie le Conseil
permanent de la Francophonie qui s'est
tenu le 6 novembre à Paris présidé par
le secrétaire général de l'OIF monsieur
abdououf qui a réuni les représentants
personnels des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement francophone la
réintégration du Mali qui fut décidée
constitue un acte fort au moment où les
Maliens viennent d'organiser leurs
élection euh
présidentielles et où il se prépare aux
prochaines échéances législatives nous
savons cependant que l'assassinat récent
de deux de nos compatriotes journalistes
RFI témoigne du fait que tous les périls
ne sont malheureusement pas encore
écartés ce conseil fut suivi jeudi et
vendredi dernier de la Conférence
ministérielle de la Francophonie qui a
défini les grands axes de l'action
multilatérale francophone et a adopté
les thèmes du prochain Sommet de la
Francophonie qui aura lieu en 2014 à
Dakar vous avez souhaité madame la
ministre mettre particulièrement
l'accent lors de cette conférence sur
l'importance du droit des femmes dans
l'espace francophone en rappelant la
tenue du premier Forum mondial de femmes
francophones qu'organisé avec l'OIF en
en mars dernier à Paris j'avais
d'ailleurs eu la chance de participer
sur votre invitation à ce moment très
enrichissant qui a notamment permis de
porter la parole de femmes courageuses
et méritante impliqué dans diverses
actions de développement mais aussi
malheureusement souvent visé en premier
lieu dans des conflits il me semble que
nous avons beaucoup à apprendre des
femmes de l'espace francophone et je
pense par exemple à l'Assemblée
nationale sénégalaise où la parité est
demise puisque la moitié des députés
sont des femmes espérant qu'un jour la
France puisse suivre ce modèle en outre
en tant que rapporteur de la mission
commune d'information sur l'action
extérieure de l'État de la France en
matière de recherche pour le
développement j'ai été amené à suivre
avec attention les les travaux du comité
interministériel de la coopération
internationale et du développement
suicide du 31 juillet 2013 dont la
décision numéro 5 rappelle que les
femmes sont des actrices essentielles du
développement ma question madame la
ministre est la suivante pouvez-vous
indiquer d'une part comment suiv à la
réintégration du Mali au sein des
instances de l'OIF va se poursuivre la
promotion des valeurs francophones vers
l'accompagnement d'une paix durable dans
ce pays d'autre part quelles sont les
prochaines étapes de la valorisation du
rôle des femmes au sein de l'espace
francophone indéiablement vecteur de
paix et de développement je vousci
merci la parole est à Madame Yamina
bengigi ministre chargée de la
Francophonie merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice je vous remercie de
m'interroger sur le Mali et la place des
femmes dans la dans l'espace francophone
le peuple malien a réussi son objectif
principal qui était d'arriver debout aux
élections présidentielles et ceci malgré
le terrorisme malgré la douleur et les
pertes endurai c'est pourquoi la
réintégration du Mali dans toute sa
dignité a été décidé par les membres du
Conseil permanent de la Francophonie le
6 novembre à Paris le président de la
République a décidé de maintenir des
forces militaires en soutien à la
minusma pour appuyer le processus
démocratique en cours c'est par les
urnes que nous combattrons les
extrémistes nous devons continuer un
laassable de promouvoir les valeurs
francophones de liberté de solidarité et
de fraternité ce sont des valeurs que
défendait Claude Verlon et giseline
Dupont ces deux journalistes de RFI
froidement exécutés ils incarner la
liberté d'informer ils l'ont payé de
leur vie madame la sénatrice j'ai mis au
cœur de mon ministère la question du
respect des droits des femmes c'est
pourquoi j'ai décidé d'organiser à Paris
le 20 mars dernier le premier Forum des
femmes francophones près de 800 femmes
sont venues témoigner du recul de leurs
droits dans de nombreux pays elles ont
réclamé plus d'équalité que cessent les
viols dans les conflit armé elles ont
réclamé plus d'égalité elles ont réclamé
du droit c'est à Kinshasa que le Dee
forum des femmes aura lieu en
2014 suite à ce forum je suis suis fière
que le Sénégal a choisi le thème des
femmes vecteur de paix acteur de
développement pour le actrice de
développement pour le prochain Sommet de
la Francophonie qui se tiendra à Dakar
en automne 2014 et j'ai proposé au nom
de la France qu'une déclaration
solennelle et spécifique sur le droit
des femmes soit formulé par les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement à l'occasion
de ce sommet le statut des femmes est un
baromètre implacable de l'état
d'avancement d'une société merci
merci la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain et
citoyen monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier ministre mes chers collègues
la situation du pays est alarmande
alarmante la
colère laissez-moi avancer vous vous en
aurez pour vous aussi la colère
notamment pour ceux qui ont souhaité le
changement en
2012 la contestation conjugue la colère
contre l'austérité les
licenciements que vous prenez et
désormais celle contre l'injustice
fiscale et c'est sur cette dernière que
je souhaite vous
interroger nous voyons bien comment la
droite le MDEF comment l'extrême droite
tente d'instrumentaliser le
mécontentement populaire pour mieux
servir leur rêve de poujadisme fiscal et
dénoncer l'impôt dénoncer les
cotisations sociales qui sont le
fondement de la solidarité le problème
pour nous n'est pas l'impôt le problème
c'est l'injustice fiscale or les
recettes inscrites au projet de loi de
finance 2014 sont éloquante à nouveau
éloquante d'un côté
139,4 milliards d'euros de TVA et 13,2
milliards de taxes sur les produits
énergétiques et de l'autre seulement
36,2 milliards d'impôts sur les sociétés
en 2014 contre 49,7 milliards en 2013
l'explication de cette baisse vous la
connaissez c'est le fameux contrat impôt
Crédit Impôt compétitivité que toutes
les entreprise touche même celle qui en
ce moment licenci à tour de bras dans
ces conditions l'augmentation de la TVA
au 1er janvier prochain en alourdissant
le coût des transports en commun des
vêtements du bois de chauffage et de
beaucoup d'autres bienens de biens et
services de première nécessité sera une
nouvelle ponction dramatique contre le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
pourtant déjà si malmené et pourquoi
cela je le répète pour compenser en
grande parti les 20 milliards d'euros
offerts sans aucune contrepartie au
patronat cette mesure au 1er janvier
risque d'être la mesure de trop vous
devriez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
remettre au plus vite en chantier une
grande réforme de justice fiscale
reconstruire un impôt sur le revenu
réellement progressif qui cesse
d'épargner les plus hauts revenus
repenser la taxation du capital et
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale remettre
à plat toutes les exonérations fiscales
et de cotisation social à l'ône d'un
seul critère leur efficacité effective
en matière d'emploi vous le savez nous
allons appeler à la mobilisation pour la
justice fiscale et la taxation du
capital et nous marcherons avec le Front
de gauche vers ber 1 décemb ain mais
sans attendre monsieur le Premier
ministre je vous demande un geste fort
annuler la hausse de la TVA au 1er
janvier ce qui serait un premier pas
vers la remise en cause d'un crédit
impôt au compétitivité inefficace et
injuste
merci la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre oui monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Pierre Laurent je
connais votre discours j'aimerais de
temps en temps que vous preniez un peu
de recul et de voir où nous dans quelle
dans quelle situation nous avons trouvé
le pays en
2012 mais ça si vous ne voulez pas
l'admettre alors évidemment vous pouvez
continuer à construire un discours qui
n'a pas comment dire une cohérence
convaincante et c'est ça votre problème
mais je voudrais vous répondre avec
respect et
sincérité oui nous avons demander un
effort aux
Français depuis
2012 mais si nous n'avions pas demandé
cet effort et nous l'avons toujours dit
compris pendant la campagne des
présidentielles puisque vous l'avez
rappelé c'est clair que si nous n'avions
pas demandé au début de ce
kakena un effort pour redresser nos
comptes publics aujourd'hui où en
serions-nous je préfère vous poser la
question à vous-même est-ce que vous
accepteriez que la le déficit budgétaire
de la France ser aujourd'hui au niveau
de
6% qui serait payé par qui par les
classes populaires et les classes
moyennes parce qu'avec un tel déficit si
nous n'avions pas réagi immédiatement en
2012 et 2013 alors nous serions dans les
mains des marchés financiers et j'aurais
aimé monsieur le sénateur Pierre Laurent
que vous reconnaissiez cette réalité qui
demande effectivement un effort de
redressement mais que si nous l'avons
fait c'est parce que nous considérons
qu'il est que notre pays retrouve sa
souveraineté pleine et entière qui ne
dépend pas des marchés financiers et de
leurs lois aujourd'hui parce qu'un
effort a été fait nous pouvons dire que
même si standard and pours donne une une
note négative à la France et bien ça n'a
pas d'influence sur les marchés
financiers parce que la signature de la
France est bonne elle est sérieuse et
que aujourd'hui nous empruntons à des
taux les plus bas et qui emprunte à des
taux des plus bas pas seulement l'État
mais aussi les entreprises et aussi les
ménages c'est parce que grâce à l'effort
des Français nous avons entrepris cet
effort de redressement mais est-ce que
pour autant nous avons entendu attendu
pour tenir compte de vos attentes en
matière de justice fiscale non mais je
ne comprends pas pourquoi vous ne l'avez
pas rappelé vous-même il me semble même
que certaines mesures vous les aviez
voté au début de ce quinen je voudrais
les rappeler c'est nous qui avons
une tranche à 45 % de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour effectivement que les
revenus les plus élevés contribuent à
cet effort que je viens de rappeler j'ai
également noté qu'à l'époque vous aviez
voté à l'époque c'està-dire dans cette
législature l'impôt le rétablissement de
l'impôt sur la fortune pour lutter
contre la rente j'ai vu que vous aviez
vous-même voté les mesures que nous
avions prises en matière de fiscalité du
capital et du travail
on nous le reproche assez on nous dit
que nous avons
troup prélevé sur le capital qui a mis
sur le même plan la fiscalité du travail
et du capital c'est notre gouvernement
alors vous l'avez même votter à l'époque
et puis nous avons pris un certain
nombre de dispositions qui ont été
combattu par la droite c'est vrai je le
reconnais concernant les niches fiscales
ce travail nous l'avons engagé et vous
évoqué la TVA mais pour
2014 c'est notre gouvernement qui a
proposé que la TVA sur les travaux à
domicile et en particulier les travaux
de rénovation thermique passent au taux
le plus bas c'est-à-dire à 5,5 % qui
vient s'inscrire dans un chantier de
rénovation thermique qui est créateur
d'emploi et qui va s'additionner à la
subvention pour les ménages qui vont
investir pour leur logement qui va
s'additionner à au prêt à taux zéro et
prês environnement qui va s'additionner
au crédit d'impôt qui permet
effectivement de bénéficier d'une aide
pour l'investissement d'un côté une
facture de chauffage qui diminue de
l'autre côté de l'investissement et qui
est créateur d'emploi en particulier
pour l'artisanat et les petites
entreprises c'est ça que nous avons fait
que nous avons entrepris alors moi je
voudrais vous poser une question à mon
tour puisqueen réalité vous votre
politique elle est simple celle qui va
vous faire manifesterutre dans quelques
jours c'est déficit déficit toujours
plus de déficit mais qui pie le déficit
qui pieie le déficit sinon les les
classes populaires et les classes
moyennes et le déficit de la France
c'est quoi concrètement c'est le
remboursement chaque année des intérêts
de l'emprunt et c'est combien le
remboursement des intérêts de l'emprunt
que nous vous avez dont vous nous avez
laissé la facture mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs de la droite 50 milliards
d'euros par an c'est plus que le budget
de l'éducation national alors si nous
faisons des efforts de redressement des
comptes publics qui effectivement
mobilisent les Français et avec des
mesures de justice fiscale c'est pour
redonner à la France des marges de
manœuvre pour investir dans l'éducation
investir dans l'innovation investir dans
la préparation de l'avenir c'est avec
vous c'est avec vous que nous pourrions
faire cela c'est à vous de décider si
c'est ça que vous voulez si vous voulez
sincèrement le redressement de la France
alors je vous invite à choisir et à ne
pas mêler systématiquement vos voix à
ceux qui courent derrière la droite et
l'extrême droite c'est-à-dire qu'il ne
se battent pas pour redresser le pays je
vous invite à nous rejoindre pour
l'avenir de la France dans la cohésion
sociale et la solidarité nationale la
parole est à Monsieur François
Fortassin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vousz merci monsieur le
Président ma question concerne l'un des
principaux défis stratégiques et
géopolitique du moment la question du
programme nucléaire iranien monsieur le
ministre alors qu'une grande partie de
la presse internationale pointe la
responsabilité de la France dans l'échec
des négociations de Genève en raison de
son intransigence qu'en est-il vraiment
que s'est-il passé monsieur le ministre
dimanche à Genève pourquoi la France
est-elle opposée au projet d'accord qui
était sur le point d'aboutir entre
l'Iran et si grande puissance sur ce
dossier très
sensible après plus de 10 années de
crise à propos du nucléaire militaire
iranien une solution paraissait àorter
de main et un accord sur le point d'être
conclu l'Iran s'engageait à à s'esser
d'enrichir son uranium à 20 % soit le
seuil critique pour fabriquer une arme
nucléaire en échange d'un
assouplissement provisoire et réversible
les sanctions qui étrangl son
économie
si nos informations sont exactes la
France aurait exigé davantage de
garanties concernant l'usine d'Arab qui
utilise le plutonium combustible
indispensable pour la fabrication de
l'arme nucléaire de même que vous auriez
souhaité monsieur le ministre des
garanties sur la neutralisation du stock
actuel d'uranium enrichi à 20 % et plus
largement sur le programme
d'enrichissement pour le dire autrement
la France aurait considéré que l'accord
qui se dessinait n'était pas de nature à
pouvoir empêcher l'Iran de poursuivre sa
marche vers la bombe atomique est-ce
bien cela monsieur le ministre mais
alors pourquoi seule la France a-t-elle
fait cette lecture du
texte monsieur le ministre comme vous
comme vous nous redoutons et nous sommes
opposés à la nucléarisation militaire
d'une puissance régionale comme l'Iran
et au risque d'une flambée de
prolifération que cela pourrait
entraîner au Moyen-Orient et comme vous
nous sommes pour le le respect des
règles internationales de non
prolifération des armes nucléaires
toutefois vous le savez monsieur le
ministre il est indispensable de
parvenir à un accord avec l'Iran lors de
la reprise des négociations le 20
novembre votre votre homologue américain
John Kerry a déclaré récemment il y aura
un bon accord ou il n'y en aura pas le
premier
ministre israélien d'ajouter qu'un
mauvais accord pourrait déboucher sur la
guerre alors monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple qu'est-ce qu'un B
accord peut-il y avoir un bon accord
pour toutes les parties à savoir
notamment l'Iran la France et les
États-Unis merci la parole est à
Monsieur le mini chargé du
développement merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur
Fortassin je vous prie évidemment
d'excuser Laurent Fabius qui est
aujourd'hui au Maroc pour une réunion
sur un autre sujet stratégique pour la
sécurité à savoir la situation en
Libye vous faites référence bien
évidemment aux discussions qui ont eu
lieu il y a quelques jours à Genève et
la position de la France a été écoutée
elle a été écoutée parce que elle repose
sur une position simple et une ligne
simple de la fermeté mais pas de
fermeture nous sommes fermes mais nous
ne sommes pas fermé et nous sommes
fermes sur une ligne qui est celle de la
communauté internationale de manière
totalement consensuelle à savoir au nom
du principe de non
prolifération le fait de refuser à
l'Iran le droit d'avoir accès à la
technologie nucléaire militaire et cette
sur cette position la France n'est en
aucun cas isolée puisque le texte qui a
été é présenté par la France a été signé
de manière unanime par ce qu'on appelle
les membres du p5+ SA à savoir les
membres du Conseil de sécurité plus
l'Allemagne il n'y a donc pas
d'isolement français sur cette question
il y a au contraire une position simple
de la fermeté au nom des principes
reconnus de manière unanime par la
communauté internationale mais de
l'ouverture de l'ouverture pour avoir un
accord un accord avec des garanties et
notamment les garanties sur les deux
points que vous avez soulevés dans votre
question à savoir la question de
l'uranium enrichi et la question de la
centrale d'Arac et du réacteur d'Arac
qui est effectivement celui qui pose
potentiellement le plus de problèmes et
à ce stade nous n'avions pas les
garanties suffisantes c'est pour ça que
bien évidemment nous redonnons notre
chance à la négociation et c'est aussi
le cas et le gouvernement et Laurent
fabus tient à le souligner c'est aussi
le cas des Iraniens qui veulent donner
leur chance à la négociation et c'est
pour ça qu'il y aura dès le 20 novembre
dans les tous prochains jours une
nouvelle réunion avec les directeurs
politiques et que nous souhaitons bien
évidemment un succès cette négociation
ça fait 10 ans qu'elle dure monsieur le
sénateur elle peut durer 10 jours de
plus pour obtenir non seulement un
changement de ton des Iraniens mais
aussi un changement de fond
merci
merci la parole est à Monsieur
pour le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire merci Monsieur
président monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation
nationale un grand ministre n'est pas
forcément celui qui dirige un grand
ministère F celui de l'éducation
nationale un grand ministre est celui
qu' montre qu'il sait écouter et
entendre les Français
depuis le début de votre réforme sur les
rythmes scolaires vous avancez très sûr
de vous mais vous n'écoutez personne
vous n'écoutez pas les enseignants qui
sont en grève aujourd'hui qui ne veulent
pas de votre réforme écoutezles monsieur
le ministre le ce sont des les
enseignants sont des gens compétents ils
sont soucieux du devenir de nos enfants
ils ont des idées pourquoi leur
imposez-vous une réforme au lieu de les
écouter au lieu de dialoguer avec eux
vous n'écoutez pas plus les parents
d'élèves les parents d'élèves qui ne
veulent pas de votre
réforme vous n'écoutez même pas ceux qui
sont entrés dans votre réforme depuis le
mois de septembre dernier ceuxl sont en
train de vous dire nos enfants n'en
peuvent plus ils sont en train de vous
dire
il et il r épuis monsieur le
ministre c'est dans 17% des communes que
votre réforme est entrée en
application pourquoi ne prenez-vous pas
le temps de tirer les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé dans ces 17% de
communes monsieur le minist vous
n'écoutez pas non plus les
élus vous nécoutez pas les élus
qu'est-ce qu'ils vous disent non mais
ils vous disent nous n'avons pas les
moyens sachez que une grande majorité
d'entre eux ne sont pas hostil à votre
réforme ils
disent nos budgets ne nous le permettent
pas ils disent mais pas simplement dans
les communes rurales même ailleurs ils
disent nous avons pas les locaux pour
organiser votre réforme ils disent nous
ne trouvons pas de personnel
compétent écoutezles monsieur le
ministre c'est ils expriment R
beaucoup d'entre nous nous sommes élus
on nous a réduit les datations de l'État
et c'est à ce moment-là que vous voulez
charger encore un peu plus les communes
le gouvernement ne peut pas d'un
côtés POS vot question en disant vous
dépensez trop pour le personnel et par
ailleurs nous demandez d'embaucher des
animateurs en plus c'est ça qu'ils
expriment monsieur le ministre donc
écoutez-les entendez-les nous vous en
donnons l'occasion nous avons le groupe
déposé une proposition de loi qui vous
permettra de répondre je dirais
calmement
à toutes ces inquiétudes donc ma
question monsieur le ministre quand
cesserez-vous d'être sourd à tous ces
messages qui viennent de tous les côtés
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateuratovski vous avez parfaitement
raison il convient d'entendre les uns et
les autres surtout sur un dossier aussi
important qui est celui de la réussite
scolaire des enfants de France et d'une
façon plus globale de leur réussite
éducative c'est un sujet de
préoccupation pour nous tous Lorsque
nous savons que 20 à 25 % de ces enfants
sont en difficulté que 150000 Linc vient
de leappeler même un peu plus sorte de
notre système scolaire sans
qualification et que les égalité
s'accroisse considérablement dans notre
pays au point que nous allons apprendre
sans doute bientôt que nous sommes même
les
recordela c'est le résultat d'un certain
nombre de choix le choix d'abord de ne
pas recruter un nombre de professeurs
suffisants le choix ensuite de ne plus
les former le choix enfin malheureux et
récent d'enlever du temps scolaire et du
temps scolaire de qualité aux enfants de
France ce choix à 4 ans le président de
la République le gouvernement ont décidé
de d'opérer le redressement de l'école
française de permettre à tous les
enfants leur réussite parce que ce sera
demain la réussite du pays toutes les
organisations internationales nous le
disent cela suppose une action résolue
de l'État refaire les programmes
embaucher des professeurs les former à
nouveau passer au numérique avoir des
dispositifs pour ceux qui sont dans le
décrochage tout ça nous le faisons avec
un budget vous le savez nous en avons
discuté en commission au Sénat cette
semaine qui est un budget prioritaire ma
préoccupation majeure c'est que les
élèves demain de ce pays 25 % nous
délinent cela puissent lire écrire et
compter lorsqu'ils arrivent en 6e et à
partir de là construire leur autonomie
leur insertion professionnelle et même
leur citoyenneté car vous noterez qu'il
y a une corrélation étroite entre
l'échec Scola et les comportements
extrémistes dont nous avons parlé alors
pour se faire il faut donner aux enfants
un temps de qualité scolaire tous les
pays d'Europe nous sommes le seul à
faire les 4 jours tous les pays d'Europe
ont au minimum l'Allemagne que vous
prenez souvent en exemple 5 jours à 6
jours ont au minimum 5 matinées de
classe parce que pour lire écrire
compter on apprend mieux à 9h30 le matin
qu'à 16h en fin de journée c'est ce que
nous faisons et en même temps nous
luttons contre les inégalités parce que
lorsque les enfants sont pas à l'école
le mercredi matin ils sont où pour les
plus déshérités d'entre eux il y a de
très belles études ils sont devant la
télévision ils sont au bas des cages
d'escaliers il sont pas dans un
dispositif éducatif ce que nous mettons
en route à côté du meilleur temps
scolaire c'est la possibilité de passer
de 20 % d'enfants à 80 % d'enfants
accueillis dans des dispositifs
périscolaires et pour se faire nous
avons besoin puisque c'est la
responsabilité des communes de les aider
nous avons parlé avec chacun les
intérêts des uns ne sont pas les
intérêts des autres on le sait depuis
longtemps dans ce pays mais on ne
construit pas un intérêt général avec
une addition d'intérêt particulcl là
c'est l'intérêt des élèves c'est
l'intérêt de la France l'écoutez là il y
a un comité de suivi nous avons déjà
proposé des aménagements nous avons
écouté les communes nous avons différé
le temps d'application nous avons créé
le fond et nous avons laissé une liberté
qui aujourd'hui fait souvent problème et
provoque chez les enseignants une
certaine colère nous continuerons parce
que nous savons que nous agissons dans
l'intérêt du pays et nous essaierons de
vous convaincre que vous pouvez vous y
associer merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Paul Amoud pour le groupeion des
démocrates et indépendants
UC merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question porte sur une
problématique celle du calendrier des
vacances scolaires qui concerne non
seulement l'éducation mais aussi
l'emploi l'économie le tourisme et les
transports ce calendrier a une très
forte influence sur l'industrie
touristique de notre pays secteur non
délocalisable qui représente 7 % du PIB
national 78 milliards et demi d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et 900000
emplois depuis 2010 la fréquentation des
stations de montagne durant les vacances
de printemps décalé sur le mois de mai a
chuté de 70 % précarisant ainsi l'emploi
de près de 35000 personnes fragilisé
parfois par les aléas météorologiques et
surtout la réduction croissante du
pouvoir d'achat des ménages les
entreprises touristiques des stations de
sport d'hiver voient leur marge
fortement impacté alors qu'elles sont
confronté à d'importantes charges fixes
et à la nécessité d'investir pour faire
face à une concurrence étrangère de plus
en plus vive et répondre aux exigences
de mise au norme de leurs équipements
hôeli remontées mécanique et cetera les
propositions du ministère de l'Éducation
pour les années scolaires de 2014 à 2017
ne tiennent pas compte de cette
situation et la grave par des lépars en
congé à mi-semaine pour l'année
2016-207 d'ailleurs cet agenda n'impacte
pas seulement les professionnels de la
montagne mais aussi ceux du littoral car
en englobant les ponts du mois mai dans
les vacances de printemps il privve les
stations du littoral de lancement de
saison dès le mois d'avril ce calendrier
réduit aussi la durée des contrat
saisonniers de travail de manière
doublement préjudiciable pour les
revenus des salariés d'une part et par
les charges supplémentaires imputées à
l'assurance chômage d'autre part tout
aussi dommageable est la perte
d'activité qui engendre pour l'État un
manque à gagner de 80 à 100 millions
d'euros de recette
fiscal enfin comment expliquer que le
calendrier des vacances scolaires soit
en pareille contradiction avec les
déclarations de Monsieur le Président de
la République qui fin août annonçait sa
volonté d'ériger le tourisme en grande
cause nationale c'est pourquoi dans le
respect de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant il doit être possible de
concilier le temps scolaire avec les
préoccupations sociales et économique
ainsi d'écrite et en particulier de
fixer en avril les vacances de printemps
aussi au-delà de l'avis que le Conseil
supérieur de l'éducation est appelé à
donner aujourd'hui même le Gouvernement
entend-il prendre véritablement en
compte ce problème a commencé par une
concertation approfondie et élargie à
l'ensemble des parties
prenantes merci la parole est à monsieur
le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
le sénateur le sujet que vous évoquez
est un sujet de de très vive
préoccupation pour les raisons que vous
avez pu dire c'est le 20 juillet 2009
qu'un de mes prédécesseurs a pris un
arrêté dont je pense l'intention était
bonne elle consistait à faire qu'il y
ait entre les vacances de Noël et de
février pour respecter les rythmes des
élèves plus de 6 semaines ce calendrier
qui a été adopté par la majorité
précédente a conduit évidemment à faire
des retours plus tardifs dans des
vacances de printemps et à provoquer les
difficultés que vous
dites c'est un arrêté c'est un arrêté
donc un arrêté du 20 juillet 2009 donc
soyez gentil de connaître la loi et
ensuite de la respecter j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire et je crois que ne peut pas
sous-estimer ma détermination sur ces
questions que la question du calendrier
scolaire des rythmes scolaires devaient
être visité dans son ensemble dans les
discussions que nous avons eu très
longues avec les représentants des élus
les représentants des professionnels
pour préparer le début de la réforme
scolaire cette question a été abordée
cette question n'a pas trouvé à ce stade
sa solution un nouveau calendrier a été
adopté pour ans mais je dis ici comme je
l'ai dit déjà publiquement si nous
arrivons à un accord sur l'année
scolaire et bien nous modifierons ce
calendrier lorsque le consensus sera
créé et l'écoutte présente à partir de
là des propositions sont faites elles
doivent quand même garder toujours comme
préoccupation première l'intérêt de
l'élève mais il n'y aura de possibilité
vous le savez de réussir ce qui n'a pas
été réussi jusqu'à présent que si nous
travaillons à l'idée d'un autre zonage
pour les grandes vacances cette question
est essentielle j'ai annoncé que
j'ouvrirai une fois que nous aurons
réussi la première étape les discussions
au courant de l'année 2015 il y a à la
fois un impératif pédagogique à
respecter et un impératif économique
nous en sommes conscients et nous
voulons avancer sur ce
chemin
merci la parole est à Madame Frédéric
Espagnac pour le groupe socialiste merci
monsieur président ma question s'adresse
à Madame la Ministre de la réforme de
l'État de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique le gouvernement a
décidé de mettre en place quelques 200
mesures de simplification administrative
après le PACT de compétitivité cette
nouvelle dimension de l'action
gouvernementale permettra de redonner de
la force à nos services publics et à
notre appareil productif en allégeant
les démarches des particuliers et des
entreprises nous répondons à une demande
très ancienne la production des normes
en France n'est plus maîtrisable
autrement que par un choc le président
de la République l'avait affirmé
lui-même le 28 mars dernier ce choc de
simplification va impacter la vie
quotidienne de tous les Français celle
des chefs d'entreprise des élus des
fonctionnaires notre majorité participe
aujourd'hui à faire évoluer les
pratiques pour plus de croissance de
compétitivité et d'emploi les Français
veulent des services publics efficaces
et compréhensibles l'action publique a
besoin de clarté de visibilité et
d'efficacité sous la présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozi ce sont plus de 260 lois
qui ont été votées dont 25 % de règles
n'ont jamais été appliquées nous
démontrons aujourd'hui que la volonté et
l'efficacité en matière de réforme et de
simplification sont porté par notre
majorité initié en avril par une
ordonnance comportant huit mesures pour
simplifier les démarches dans
l'immobilier et l'urbanisme d'entreprise
et conforté par le rapport Mandon remis
le 1er juillet dernier qui vise à
supprimer d'ici 2016 80 % des coûts des
entreprises liées à la complexité
administrative ce choc est devenu l'une
des priorités du gouvernement par la
suite deux grands projets de loi visant
à simplifier à la fois les règles
d'application à la construction de
logement mais aussi les relations entre
les citoyens et l'administration ont été
adopté en juillet et en octobre dernier
et publié hier au Journal officiel deux
autres textes relatifs à la
simplification de la vie des entreprises
et à leur relation des citoyens avec la
justice le seront dans les semaines à
venir et un comité de suivi veillera à
l'application de ces mesures madame la
ministre pouvez-vous donc nous donner
des précisions ainsi qu'aux français qui
nous regardent sur la mise en œuvre
enfin de ce choc de iication mais aussi
sur les mesures que le Gouvernement
contre prendre pour aller encore plus
loin dans cette démarche visant à
libérer les énergies de notre pays
favoriser les créateurs l'innovation et
favoriser le processus de création de
richesse et d'emploi je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Marie Lise
Lebranchu ministre de la réforme de
l'État de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Frédérique espagac c'est vrai
que le président de la République a fixé
le cap en mai dernier il déclarait plus
de simplification c'est plus d'initiativ
plus d'activités plus d'emploi plus de
simplification c'est plus de temps pour
nos concitoyens plus de vie plus de
croissance cela fait partie des réformes
qui peuvent nous permettre simplement de
vivre mieux le gouvernement s'est donc
engagé résolument dans l'action pour
simplifier les normes et faciliter la
vie des entreprises des citoyens et des
fonctionnaires et vous l'avez souligné
madame Espagnac le gouvernement veut
aller vite c'est pourquoi il procède par
hord donance et le Parlement vous l'avez
souligné a déjà adopté deux textes sur
l'administration et sur le logement vous
discutez en ce moment de celui qui a
trait aux entreprises et qui sera
discuté très précisément me dit-on sur
ces bans le 12 décembre avec Pierre
Moscovici et bientôt viendra celui
relatif et il est très important et
peut-être n'y avions-nous pas assez
prêté attention à celui qui concerne les
procédures judiciaire puisqueune enquête
auprès de nos concitoyens montre à quel
point nous pouvons faire mieux rapidité
efficacité c'est ce que nous avons fait
j'espère avec deux types de démarche
d'abord le Premier ministre préside
lui-même le comité interministériel de
la modération de l'action publique il a
créé cette avec moi qui en est une
responsabilité partagé le secrétariat
général de la modération de l'action
publique et le 17 juillet dernier nous
avons fait une première série de
propositions je NIS pas tout vous
énumérer ici mais elles sont publiques
et à votre disposition mais avec des
choses extrêmement importantes par
exemple suivre sur Internet l'avancement
d'un dossier de demande de passeport ou
de demande d'autorisation vous pouvez
savoir en amont qu'il y a un problème
sur leur dossier qui manque une pièce et
cetera ce qui permet aux créateurs à
l'usager aux citoyens d'être informé en
amont et pas à postériori prise de
rendez-vous en ligne je vous passe
beaucoup de sujets parce qu'ils sont
importants mais je voudrais souligner en
plus qu'avec an mondbour le groupe de
Monsieur Mandon que vous avez souligné
le groupe de Monsieur poitrimoil mais
aussi le texte qui a été été porté par
Jean-Pierre sur et et Jacqueline gourau
qui nous permet aussi d'associer la
simplification des normes nous avons
pris un engagement c'est de vous
soumettre à vous les parlementaires de
la Haute Assemblée comme à vos collègues
députés les compes rendu du sac pour que
vous soyez la vigilance de chaque
citoyen français parce que les listes de
simplification sont longues les
explications sont intéressantes mais il
nous reste beaucoup à faire
merci la parole est à monur monsieur
alberri de montgolphier pour le groupe
Union pour un mouvement populaire merci
monsieur le Président ma question porte
sur le prochain loi projet loi de
finances dont nous allons commencer
l'examen dans cet hémicycle la semaine
prochaine puisque en août dernier le
ministre Pierre Moscovici et je vais
reprendre ses propres termes avait
évoqué le ralbol fiscal des ménages des
consommateurs et des entreprises c'est
une citation et le gouvernement nous
avait annoncé un PLF pour 2014 qui dont
l'effort porterait à 80 % sur la dépense
et à 20 % sur la fiscalité mais mais la
lecture du projet loi de finances pour
2014 montre que cette présentation ne
correspond absolument pas à la réalité
la réalité la réalité des chiffres c'est
quoi la réalité des chiffres est ce que
les dépenses du budget général entre le
PLF 2013
295,2 milliards d'euros et le PLF pour
294,5 milliards d'euros la baisse des
dépenses netoralité que de 700 millions
700 millions car vous devez financer un
certain nombre de promesses électorales
et je pense en particulier aux EMBA dans
un nombre de ministères la réalité des
chiffres c'est la baisse des dotations
de l'État qui elle est réelle 1
milliards 5 de baisse de dotation pour
les communes pour les intercommunalités
pour les départements pour les régions
in 1,5 milliards auxquels doivent
s'ajouter 2 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires en particulier
pour les rythme scolaire on en a parlé 2
milliards d'euros supplémentaires c'est
le chiffrage du Comité des finances
locales la réalité c'est également pour
le gouvernement une hausse des
cotisations d'impôts une hausse des
cotisations sociales qui va concerner
directement les entreprises je pense
bien sûr à l'IS qui va concerner les
ménages je pense à la TVA bref c'est
environ 12 milliards d'euros de
prélément supplémentaire pour les
français pour les familles en 2014 la
réalité c'est évidemment que les
Français ne croient plus à l'annonce
d'une poste fiscale que vous n'évoquez
d'ailleurs même plus les Français
attendent des réponses ils attendent des
réponses maintenant pour ce projet de
loi de finance pour 2014 ils n ils n
attendent pas des commentaires des
critiques sur les budgets précédents ce
la présidente mandature ils n'attendent
pas non plus des promesses pour les
futurs budgets ceux de 2015 ils
attendent des réponses pour maintenant
et ma question est extrêmement simple au
cours de ce débat budgétaire qui
commence quelles dépenses allez-vous
accepter de réduire comme vous y invite
d'ailleurs le CDE et en bref quelle
réponse allez-vous apporter au ralbol
fiscal des Français
merci la parole est à Madame flur
pèlerin mini chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je vous
prie tout d'abord de bien vouloir
excuser pierre moscoviss que je supplis
cet après-midi alors nous pouvons séance
après séance rejouer sans cesse la même
partition avec sans cesse les mêmes
questions et donc toujours les les mêmes
réponses car chaque semaine c'est la
même question que vous que vous nous
posez et ce sont les mêmes réponses que
je vais devoir vous faire puisque vous
en décidez ainsi comme chaque semaine je
serai dans l'obligation de vous rappeler
que l'opposition est quand même bien
prompte à s'exonérer de ses
responsabilités alors de commenter la
trajectoire budgétaire de ce pays car
les décisions que nous prenons
aujourd'hui ne sont finalement que les
répliques à votre propre gestion et s'il
y a décrochag de économie française
aujourd'hui il y a il a eu lieu hélas
bien avant que nous arrivions vous nous
laissez un déficit à 5,5 % du PIB 600
milliards d'euros de dett supplémentair
un commerce extérieur au plus bas alors
oui nous devons réparer et réparer au
plus vite et comme chaque semaine je
vous rappellerai que malgré malgré vous
malgré les cassandres la situation
économique de notre pays s'améliore
progressivement tous les instituts
économiques le confirment la récession
est der nous la croissance revient
progressivement certes le chômage se
stabilise et nous le devons pour partie
à l'action de ce gouvernement comme
chaque semaine vous nous accusez de
matraquage fiscal laissz entendre que si
vous étiez resté au pouvoir les choses
auraient été tellement plus dou et
tellement plus simple vous auriez su
réduire les dépenses sans Hurter
l'économie mais que n'avez-vous fait
pendant les 10 années où vous avez été
au responsabilité vous auriez su éviter
les Hauses d'apô mais alors pourquoi ne
pas avoir mis en pratique cet engagement
au cours des dernières années la
précédente majorité a voté rien que pour
les années 2011 et 2012 pas moins de 35
milliards d'impôts supplémentaire alors
comme chaque semaine je vous rappellerai
que la dépense publique elle est
désormais maîtrisée nous intensifions
même nos efforts d'économie en 2014
année qui marquera un basculement dans
la répartition de nos efforts entre
recettes et dépenses pierre moscovissi
et Bernard casenuve ont élaboré un
budget 2014 très ambitieux puisqu'il
prévoit une baisse de 1,5 milliards
d'euros de dépenses de l'État hors
dettes et pension
c'est d'ailleurs la première fois qu'un
budget est construit sur une base aussi
ambitieuse je rappelle que pendant le
précédent quinquena pendant le précédent
quinena les dépenses ont progressé en
moyenne de 2 milliards d'euros par an
voilà votre bilan comme nous vous
l'expliquons depuis des semaines et
depuis des mois l'effort d'orénavant et
à partir de 2015 se fera uniquement par
des économies et pour cela nous nous
donnons les moyens nous mettons en œuvre
les réformes structurelles qui ont été
évoqué par mariise de branchu celle que
vous avez sans cesse reporté avec la
modernisation de l'action publique la
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
l'action sur la sur les retraites et le
chantier de la simplification alors vous
le voyez monsieur le sénateur nous reons
chaque semaine la même scène vous posez
les mêmes questions nous donnons les
mêmes réponses et au fond que
faisons-nous si ce n'est ce que vous
n'avez su faire pendant 10 ans merci
merci la parole est à Monsieur Michel
bçon pour le groupe
socialiste ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre en charge
des PME de innovation et du
numérique la France se situe au 6e rang
mondial pour la recherche
scientifique mais elle n'arrive qu'à la
16e place pour l'innovation
technologique certes la France a
contribuer à mettre au point des
technologies de rupture qui ont permis
par exemple l'émergence des
biotechnologies ou du numérique mais la
France n'a pas su transformer tous ses
atouts technologiques en at tout
industriel d'où un décrochage depuis 10
ans de la compétitivité de nos entrepris
avec ses conséquences sur l'emploi et
sur les comptes publics aujourd'hui nous
savons tous que le premier levier de la
compétitivité c'est
l'innovation l'enjeu pour notre pays est
donc de placer l'innovation au cœur de
nos politiques
publiques d'encourager le développement
des écosystèmes favorbles à
l'innovation de doter l'innovation
d'outils d'impulsion de pilotage et
d'évaluation pour faire face à cet enjeu
le Premier ministre a lancé le 4
novembre le plan une nouvelle donne pour
l'innovation un plan je souhaite le
rappeler ici qui prolonge les mesures
prises après la publication du rapport
loi je les rappelle le pacte national
pour la croissance le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi le crédit d'impôt
innovation la banque publique
d'investissement les 34 projets pour les
filières industrielles de demain les 10
orientations pour refonder la politique
de transfert dans la recherche
scientifique jamais je dis bien jamais
un gouvernement navait pris au moins
pendant au moins d'un an autant de
mesures qui donne force qui donne sens à
la politique de redressement de notre
économie et le plan une nouvelle donne
pour l'innovation va renforcer ce
redressement madame le ministre vous
venez de présenter les 40 mesures
concrètes de ce plan avec la volonté
avez-vous dit de faire émerger un modèle
à la
française alors comment le Gouvernement
entend-il promouvoir cette culture de
l'innovation qui nous fait souvent
défaut comment entend-il c'est notre
faiblesse favoriser le développement
commercial des inventions et des idées
nouvelles comment entend-il encourager
la prise de risque par les innovateurs
et combler le manque chronique de
financement des entreprises innovantes
je vous remercie Madame le Ministre pour
vos réponses
merci madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bon vous avez raison je
commencerai par là de signaler
qu'effectivement depuis un an le
gouvernement a mis beaucoup en œuvre
pour une politique une véritable
politique de l'innovation vous avez
raison aussi de souligner que au cours
des 10 dernières années en revanche peu
a été fait pour stimuler l'innovation
dans notre pays alors vous avez rappelé
un certain nombre de vous avez rappelé
un certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
mises en œuvre à la suite de du Pacte
pour pour la la CRO croissance la
compétitivité et l'emploi le Crédit
Impôt Recherche l'extension à
l'innovation le statut du Jeune
Entreprise Innovante étendu elle aussi à
l'innovation 2 % de la commande publique
réservée à des entreprises innovantes ce
sont déjà des premières mesures que nous
avons commencé à mettre en œuvre et puis
il est vrai le le Premier ministre m'a
confié le soin de coordonner un plan
pour l'innovation afin d'avoir une
politique complémentaire des plans pour
le des de la nouvelle-fance industrielle
d'Arnaud Montebourg qui sont des
politiques sectorielles il s'agit cette
fois d'avoir une politique transve pour
pour l'innovation alors le premier axe
le premier axe et bien c'est
l'innovation par tous l'innovation elle
nî elle naît de le la mobilisation de
tous les talents c'est une aventure
humaine qui dont le ressort est la
créativité qui implique des hommes et
des femmes de toutes origines et de
toute formation je citerai juste deux
actions emblématiques de de ce plan le
soutien au projet de développement de la
culture de l'entrepreneuriat et de
l'innovation doté de 20 millions d'euros
sur le programme d'investissement
d'avenir donc j'ai obtenu la création au
sein de de ce programme et puis la
création d'une bourse pour les nouveaux
entrepreneurs qui sera dotée d'une
dizaine de millions d'euros par an pour
accompagner des porteurs de projet dans
leur soix de créer une entreprise pour
ceux qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir
dans leur famille ou dans leur entourage
les moyens financiers de lancer leur
leur projet entrepreneurial le deuxième
axe c'est l'innovation ouverte
l'innovation vous le savez bien elle ne
se planifie pas elle nî dans les
écosystèmes vous avez prononcé ce mot
elle naît de la rencontre entre des
acteurs d'univers différents des
chercheurs et des grandes entreprises
des grandes entreprises et des PME des
ingénieurs et des designers et c'est
cela qu'il nous faut soutenir la
dynamique des écosystèmes c'est-à-dire
la dynamique des territoires pour se
faire nous mobiliserons les grands
groupes à travers un un partenariat pour
l'innovation ouverte que nous allons
signer en début de d'année 2014 avec les
principales organisation représentant
les entreprises nous essaierons de
traiter des sujets comme l'essmage le
corporate venture le mesena de
compétence la commande privée innovante
et cetera l'idée étant d'essayer de
chasser en meut pour faire gagner
l'innovation à la la française le
troisème axe du plan c'est l'innovation
pour la croissance l'idée c'est que
l'innovation est portée par des
entreprises qu'il faut les accompagné
notamment le financement de l'innovation
doit être accompagné et soutenu par
l'État ce plan il est fait pour les
entreprises innovantes de croissance et
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce plan
met l'accent sur le soutien à
l'industrie du financement de
l'innovation le capital risque et le
capital développement avec des mesures
de simplification pour les FIP et les
FCPI et puis un amortissement fiscal
pour les investissements des grandes
entreprises et puis 4è axe l'innovation
publique face à l'innovation continue
l'État doit évaluer et mieux améliorer
les résultats des politiques publiques
en faveur de l'innovation mieux en
mesurer l'impact c'est extrêmement
important et donc vous l'avez compris
monsieur le sénateur cette nouvelle
donne pour l'innovation renforce la
démarche sectorielle des 34 plans pour
pour l'innovation présenté par AR
merci la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Noël
Cardou pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement
populaire
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
de l'artisanat et du commerce faire
vivre nos territoire c'est leur donner
les moyens d'exister et le premier de
ces moyens est certainement de permettre
aux entreprises qui s'y trouvent de se
développer aux quatre coins de notre
pays les artisans les commerçants les
travailleurs indépendants lancent un cri
d'alarme pour attirer l'attention sur
leur situation qui se dégrade très
gravement six entreprises disparaissant
chaque heure soit 54000 défaillance par
an il est de notre voix de notre devoir
à nous élus des territoires de les
écouter et de tout faire pour inverser
une situation qui n'a rien
d'irréédiable l'accumulation des
prélévements sociaux et fiscaux et des
contraintes administratives est à
l'origine de les expération de tous ces
chefs d'entreprise car ils supporteront
1,2 milliards d'euros de prélèvement
supplémentaires en 2013 et 2014 c'estes
sacrifiés mais pas résignés viennent
s'ajouter à tous ces mouvements
d'entrepreneurs et contribuable pigeon
poussin abeilles tondu qui se sont
rebellés contre l'aspixie fiscale leur
survie un celle que ainsi que Cell de
nos territoires sont en jeu avec toutes
les conséquences sur l'emploi puisqu'ils
sont de loin le premier employeur de
France avec 150000 emplois offerts
chaque année alors les discours
lénifiants sont autant de déclarations
d'affichage pendant que le gouvernement
continue son entreprise de destruction
sans prendre conscience
que trop d'impôt tue l'impôt parmi les
exemples citons le déplafonnement des
cotisations sociales maladie et
vieillesse plus récemment la création de
ce compte pénibilité véritable usine à
gaz pour les entreprises et la
perspective de l'augmentation de la TVA
en 2014 fort heureusement hier
après-midi le Sénat dans sa grande
sagesse comme d'ailleurs sur l'ensemble
du texte a rejeté l'article 10 du projet
de loi de financement de la Sécurité
social déplafonnant les cotisations
vieillesses des travailleurs
indépendants quand madame la ministre et
comment allez-vous cesser de paupériser
les classes moyennes dans une France en
Grande Dépression bloquant dès l'origine
toute volonté
d'entreprendre
merci la parole est à Madame sylvia
Pinel ministre de l'Artisanat du
Commerce et du Tourisme merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
m'interroger sur la fiscalité pesant sur
les entreprises du du commerce et les
entreprises artisanales et vous semblait
dire que le gouvernement ne se
préoccuperait pas de ce secteur c'est un
peu c'est complètement inexact et c'est
très caricatural le ton de de votre
question parce que depuis plus d'un an
et demi le contact que j'ai noué avec
les organisation professionnelle est
permanent et continu et régulier parce
que je partage un point point avec vous
c'est la nécessité d'avoir sur
l'ensemble de nos territoires les
territoires urbains comme les
territoires ruraux des entreprises du
commerce de proximité des entreprises
artisanales qui créent de l'emploi qui
créent du savoir-faire qui transmettent
leurs entreprises qui transmettent leurs
compétences et qui donneent aussi
au-delà de l'aspect économique beaucoup
de liens social dans ces territoires
depuis plus d'un an le gouvernement a
agi en faveur de ces entreprises d'abord
avec le PCT pour la compétitivité et le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi qui
bénéficie très largement à ces
entreprises puisque la griille des
salaires et correspond aux
bénéficiaaires du cice nous avons aussi
mis en place un fond pour la trésorerie
de ces entreprises avec la BPI d'un fond
de 500 millions d'euros accessible au
TPE PME nous avons aussi encourager et
faciliter la transmission de ces
entreprises qui peinent souvent à
trouver repreneur avec le volet
transmission du contrat de génération et
puis nous allons continuer nos efforts
en 2014 sur la concurrence déloyale en
luttant contre le travail illégal en
faisant un effort important pour le
secteur de l'artisanat du bâtiment avec
l'application du taux réduit de TVA pour
la construction et la rénovation de
logements sociaux avec les primes qu'a
rappelé le Premier ministre tout à
l'heure et avec le taux de TVA réduit
pour des travaux de rénovation thermique
nous je présenterai également un projet
de loi en faveur des entreprises de
l'artisanat du commerce et des TPE pour
simplifier les parcours de l'entreprise
individuelle pour favoriser et maîtriser
l'évolution des loyers commerciaux pour
simplifier les règles d'urbanisme et
puis monsieur le sénateur nous avons
avec le ministre du Budget depuis
plusieurs semaines engagé un travail
pour définir les modalités du taux
d'application de TVA et travailler sur
de nombreuses autres mesures et je note
que vous n'avez pas soulevé les
réactions positives des fédérations
professionnelles à l'issue de ces
entretiens ce travail va se poursuivre
parce que nous avons besoin pour le
redressement économique de ces
entreprisesl alors que vous vous les
avez oublié pendant plus de 10 ans
merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis
Masson vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci merci monsieur monsieur
le Président ma ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre tout au
moins s'il avait été présent les cotax
sur les poids lourds monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Premier ministre
l'écotax sur les poids lourds a été
proposé par le gouvernement Fillon et
voté à la quasi unanimité des
parlementaire de droite comme de gauche
cette mesure de bon sens a un double
intérêt tout d'abord pour
l'environnement elle favorise le
feroutage et réduit les flux de poids
lourd ensuite en période de restriction
budgétaire cette écotaxe ferait payer à
juste titre les poids lourds étrangers
qui contribueraient ainsi à la réflex
des routes j'ai pour ma part j'ai
toujours soutenu le principe de
l'échotaxe et je déplore la démagogie
des responsables politiques à droite
comme à gauche qui l'ont voté et qui
prétendent maintenant qu'il faut la
supprimer je déplore aussi la faiblesse
de gouvernement car en cédant devant
n'importe quelle manifestation de rue on
encourage les uns et les autres à se
dresser contre l'autorité de l'État
je en particulier la réaction populiste
des soi-disant Bonet rougge breton est
complètement injustifié faut-il rappeler
que la Bretagne est l'une des quatre
régions de France où le taux de chômage
est le plus faible et que les problèmes
en Bretagne en matière d'emploi ils sont
sans commune mesure avec ceux que l'on
connaît dans le Nord ou en Lorine il n'y
a donc aucune raison de consentir un
régime de faveur il n'y avait donc
aucune raison de consentir un régime de
faveur en accordant une réduction de 50
% sur l'écotaxe en Bretagne à forciori
il n'y aurait aucune raison d'y
supprimer lesécotaxe à moins que les
Bretons ne financent d'orénavant
eux-mêmes leur voie rapide toutes
gratuite c'est le seul cas en France qui
sont payés jusqu'à présent avec les
impôts de tous les
Français enfin suite aux
restructurations militaires désastreuses
qui ont fait perdre 4500 emplois à mes
l'État s'était engagé à y fixer le siège
des kou et du service des douanes
associé plusieurs centaines de personnes
ont été embauché ou devait l'être avant
la fin de l'année en reculant face au
bonnet rouge le gouvernement est
responsable d'un véritable drame social
et humain ainsi il y a 3 jours le
contrat de plus de 100 personnes a été
résilié et les les intéressés sont
obligés maintenant de retourner à Pôle
Emploi merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre je vous pose donc
une double question tout d'abord quand
le gouvernement va-t-il enfin se décider
à faire preuve d'autorité en faisant
respecter l'État et les lois de la
République ensuite les tergiversations
du gouvernement ont des conséquences
dramatiques comme je l'ai indiqué pour
des centaines de salariés de la région
messine que comptez-vous faire pour eux
monsieur le ministre merci la parole est
à monie ministgé des rel Parlement merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur maçon contte tenu de de vos
propos j'ai Imagineer un instant laisser
mariise Lebranchu vous répondre contte
tenu des propos que vous avez tenu sur
la Bretagne et que le gouvernement ne
partage absolument pas s'agissant des
comov une enquête préliminaire comme
vous le savez est ouverte et par
conséquent l'exécutif naturellement doit
s'abstenir sur les conditions de
passation du Marché de tout commentaire
ce qui est sûr aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y
a un contrat qui est signé et vous
l'avez rappelé et il faut le dire ce
contrat signé en 2011 sous le
gouvernement Fignon entraînerait si il
n'était pas appliqué une indemnité de
résiliation de 800 millions d'euros quel
sont nos obligations aujourd'hui d'abord
respecter la signature de l'État je l'ai
rappelé mais aussi en demandant au
cocontractants et il y a une négociation
en cours de respecter ses engagements
contractuels c'est le travail que fait
aujourd'hui Pierre euh Moscovici pour
l'écotax et sur le principe vous l'avez
dit l'écotax servira au développement et
à l'entretien de nos infrastructures de
transport et marquera un tournant dans
une politique en faveur du développement
durable de nombreux pays européens
faut-il le rappeler l'ont d'ailleurs
déjà mis en place
l'écotaxe puisqu'on l'appelle comme ça
n'est pas une taxe supplémentaire mais
un péage pour les poids lourd qui vise à
faire payer les usagers de la route
plutôt que les contribuables c'est une
sources de substitution à des
subventions qui sont aujourd'hui payées
par le contribuable notre deuxième
objectif c'est de mettre en place cet
écotaxe dans cette écotaxe poids lourd
dans un souci de justice sociale et il
reste vous le savez des difficultés pour
les agriculteurs pour le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire mais aussi pour les
transporteurs nous les entendons c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans un souci
d'apaisement le Premier ministre a
décidé d'un dialogue supplémentaire au
niveau national et régional pour définir
les aménagements nécessaires le
Parlement dans son ensemble s'est saisi
de cette question votre assemblée par
l'intermédiaire d'une commission
d'enquête l'Assemblée nationale a décidé
d'une mission d'information plus
particulièrement sur la question du
principe même de l'échotax sur son
intérêt sur la comparaison avec ce qui
se fait dans les autres dans les autres
dans les autres États et à l'issue
naturellement nous pourrons reprendre
nos travaux le gouvernement est attentif
aux conséquences sociales de la
suspension pour ecomove qui s'est
implanté sur le site de la base aérienne
de mes la grande majorité des personnes
embauchées pour la mise en place de
l'écotaxe l'ont été en contrat à durée
indéterminée et leur emploi n'est pas à
ce stade menacé mais hélas quelques
contrats à durée déterminée signé ne
peuvent être renouvelés le temps de la
suspension merci monsieur ministre nous
en avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au voilà donc pour ces
questions d'actualité en direct du
scénat cet après-midi on se retrouve
tout de suite pour refaire ensemble la
séance